Wizards of the Coast has been printing
Commander-specific legendary creatures
since 2011, cards designed specifically
to be put in the command zone.
As you might expect, these have not been
without controversy. Powerful designs
like Yuriko and Edgar Markov stretch the
mechanics of the Commander format to its
outer limit, and all sorts of other
cards are controversial in their own
right, even if they're less obvious
mechanical outliers. This month I want
to talk about the design and gameplay
philosophy behind several iconic but
controversial Commanders. Specifically,
whether they accomplish the goal of
being fun and dynamic game pieces, or
whether they're mistakes that should be
avoided at all costs in the future.
I'll get to some more controversial
options in later videos, but for now
we'll be keeping things simple. I want
to talk about glass cannon Commanders,
Commanders that are powerful and
explosive, but also fragile. More
specifically, I want to talk about how
these cards, while certainly having some
benefits, can risk misleading players
and causing them to stumble into play
experiences they don't necessarily want.
Something else that's fragile, though,
is your Magic Gathering decks, which is
why you should consider some extremely
cool-looking accessories from this
video's sponsor, Void Monster. Void
Monster is run by Magic Gathering artist
Forest Imel, and features some pretty
fantastic original designs. The color
playmats are a great evergreen option,
and there's also a new drop every month
available for only a limited time. This
month is the Devoid drop, which includes
a playmat, a deck box, and a bonus mana
tracker card if you buy the bundle. I
love the sort of chalky austere exterior
paired with the writhing blue tentacles
on the interior. This perfectly
encapsulates Eldrazi to me. If this drop
interests you, you can follow the link
in my description and pre-order before
October 19th. Thanks to Void Monster for
sponsoring the video. Okay, so glass
cannon Commanders. There are plenty of
recent Commanders that fit this
description, and I'll get to one of the
most infamous examples of this in a
little while. But for now we need to dig
into the origins of this sort of design
by discussing the first-ever Commander
set. Commander 2011 was quite
experimental and out there for the time,
and there are lots of things here I
could talk about. The poor by
present-day standards construction of
the precons, the reprinting of the
ultimately banned Trade Secrets, some
intriguing early attempts at political
tools the Jeskai deck, and other
assorted oddities. This set also
contains a lot of interesting early
attempts at Commander first designs,
legendary creatures designed
specifically with the intent of being
Commanders, and which try to fit that
mechanical role as a centerpiece
creature. Of the Commanders in this set,
two have really stood the test of time,
Kaalia of the Vast and Animar, Soul of
the Elements. Sitting at number five and
number 29 most popular among all
Commanders at present day, respectively,
these have endured as potent designs in
a way that other Commander options from
this set, like Gavony and Riku, simply
could not. And this makes sense. Far
from being crowded out by any old
graveyard or tokens or spell copy
Commander, these two are unique and
embody their play styles in a way that's
difficult to replicate.
Take Kaalia. She's a four-mana 2/2 flyer
in Mardu colors who lets her controller
put into play an Angel, Demon, or Dragon
tapped and attacking whenever she
attacks. The merging of these three big
flying creature types associated with
three different colors is quite iconic
and specific to Kaalia, and though her
creature cheating functionality shares
some similarities with more recent
designs like Akroma, the Unrepentant and
Mister Foxglove, no other card
accomplishes this cheating quite the way
Kaalia does. The same goes for Animar.
Though there are other cards that can
provide deep discounts for creature
spells, such as Rakdos and Hamza, these
generally require a bit more specificity
in their play patterns to pay off big.
Animar, on the other hand, is a fully
preassembled creature storm engine. The
only step to making creatures cheaper is
casting creatures, and it's not hard to
see how this could lead to some dramatic
turns without much setup required. In
short, both of these Commanders have a
specific and iconic niche that they
embody well.
This is one part of their popularity,
and the other is simply that they're
efficient at their role. Each of these
cards has a high ceiling, and achieving
a powerful game state doesn't require as
many steps as a lot of other Commanders,
simply requiring having cards in hand
ready to deploy and avoiding opposing
removal. But what about the floor?
The biggest weakness of these two
Commanders is that their game plans are
a bit brittle and not particularly hard
to set back to basically square one. To
fully get into why I'd apply a label
like glass cannon to these, we should
really discuss the nature of what
Commanders provide for various decks.
Fundamentally, all Commanders will be an
enabler, a payoff, or something in
between. Payoffs are the most common.
Ishin doubles on attack triggers,
amplifying the volume of gameplay
produced with these, and Atraxa gives
proliferates, which amplify the power of
cards that use counters.
These feel nice to play because the play
pattern is simple and effective. You
start putting together a game plan with
cards the Commander synergizes with, and
then you drop the Commander after a bit
to turbocharge that game plan. Enabler
Commanders are less common. Zur the
Enchanter is the only card in the top
100 Commanders I'd call a pure enabler,
as he isn't really a payoff for anything
at all aside from maybe having a pair of
lightning greaves and some cool
enchantments to grab in library. You
play him so you can start tutoring out
enchantments, and then your game plan
gets built up from there. This end of
things is closer to where Animar and
Kaalia live, with Animar being a slight
enabler and Kaalia being a moderate
enabler. On a basic level, being an
enabler isn't a bad thing. My favorite
decks feature Commanders that fall
closer to the enabling end of the
spectrum. However, enabler Commanders
are inherently trickier to make play
well because of the nature of the
enabler-payoff relationship. Whereas a
payoff Commander is the amplifying
adornment atop a solid 99, an enabler
Commander will a lot of times be step
one to doing anything in the game, with
the rest of the deck living atop it. To
be clear, this isn't always a problem.
If there are other ways to get the
enabling component, it can be fine. If
the enabling component is hard to
prevent or set back, it can be fine. And
if the enabling component isn't
essential to the deck's functionality,
it can be fine. The issue should
hopefully be becoming clearer. These
caveats go frequently unfulfilled with
each of these Commanders. Kaalia of the
Vast's role is to cheat permanents into
play, and she's generally an important
enabler for the big flying creatures
game plans she's played with.
Can the deck do its game plan without
her? Not really. The average Kaalia deck
has 36 lands and 11 pieces of ramp in
it, numbers far too small for a deck
with an average mana value over four.
Next you might ask, can it at least
protect her? And the answer is kind of.
Hasty boots are golden here, and you can
certainly add other cards that can
protect Kaalia early, such as Mother of
Runes or Deflecting Swat.
However, this is complicated by the fact
that the deck is also vulnerable to
board wipes, since it's a low-velocity
big creature midrange deck. So ideally
your protection suite can help that out
as well.
This might allude to the fundamental
challenge with building Kaalia, deck
space. Ideally the deck will want some
single-target protection to deal with
early pinpoint removal, as well as some
board protection and a healthy draw
suite to let it manage wipes, plus a
healthy count of lands and ramp to help
the deck bounce back from all
challenges.
Going higher on the counts of all of
these things could let the deck feel
more flexible and resilient, but also
risks removing some of the bite of the
deck. As the count of Angels, Demons,
and Dragons dips lower to offer other
things to the deck, the aggressive
options to choose from for Kaalia
triggers will also typically dip, and
you'll run out of creatures to cheat out
earlier and more often. It's no surprise
then that a lot of Kaalia players take
the opposite approach, lower land
counts, lower protection counts,
focusing on powerful beaters rather than
card draw, even including amplifier
permanents like Ishin and Windcrag Siege
that can further pump up the
explosiveness of the deck. Why play some
neutered halfway consistent Kaalia deck
when you can live out your most daring
Mardu fantasies, to stray ever closer to
the sun with your cool flyers? On the
surface, Animar might seem quite a bit
different from this. It's typically more
reliant on early draws to start
presenting a threat at the table, but
its relationship with opposing
interaction is arguably less
problematic. At worst you'll empty your
hand into a board wipe and lose a bunch
of resources, but unlike with Kaalia,
the 99 typically features a decent
amount of draw and ramp, allowing for
smoother recoveries. At best, Animar can
turn a deck into a high-velocity
machine. Even without an Ancestral
Statue infinite combo, with the right
draw engines, ramp engines, and maybe a
haste enabler, you can empty a hefty
portion of your hand onto the board in a
single turn, possibly deleting an
opponent in the process if you can swing
or get some Terror of the Peaks
triggers.
The Commander also has a bit of built-in
protection as well, unlike Kaalia,
dodging about half of all popular
pinpoint removal. So there certainly are
differences between these. Where these
Commanders are similar, though, is in
their power profile and in the
difference between the floor and the
ceiling of their game plan. Due to the
fact that both of these Commanders are
enablers that discount large amounts of
mana on creatures, in the most ideal
games with the best draws and the least
opposing interaction, they're exploding
out of control. Meanwhile, if draws are
worse, particularly for Animar, or if
there's more interaction, particularly
for Kaalia, the function of discounting
creature spells isn't as helpful. Quite
a lot of Commanders feature the phrase
"draw a card" or some equivalent in
their text box. And while you could
argue that generic value is a little
overplayed as a payoff for a Commander
to grant, this design choice has had the
undeniable boon of improving the
resilience of a lot of play styles. The
Commander of a deck is a card that's
available at all times, and assuming the
draw condition isn't too hard, having
that permanent eighth card in hand be a
draw spell reduces the risk of stall
outs and improves recovery. If you need
to hit land drops, drawing cards can
find you lands. If you're looking for
specific synergy pieces, drawing cards
can get you closer to those as well. If
you just got board wiped, as long as you
drew some cards before that happened,
you'll hopefully have some options for
rebuilding. A value engine commander
typically won't be the most threatening
or aggressive choice, but it will
usually be a safer and more consistent
one, all things equal. Your command zone
secures you exactly one element of your
deck, and though you can try to sculpt
your 99 to lead to a well-balanced
experience, there will still only be one
card in your deck that you're absolutely
guaranteed to see.
This is why the most explosive decks out
there typically feature an explosive
commander focused on either damage or
raw board size. And a pretty infamous
example of this that I'd also apply the
glass cannon label to is Jodah, the
Unifier.
Jodah is a five-color commander that
gives your legendaries plus X plus X,
where X is the number of legendary
creatures you control, and who also
gives your legendary spells you cast
from hand legendary cascade.
Unlike the commanders from 2011 I
discussed earlier, this card is closer
to the payoff end of the enabler payoff
spectrum. However, it ends up fitting a
similar profile to those other two due
to how absurdly efficient it is at one
specific task, getting power and
toughness onto board.
The two lines of text on the card can
combine to create utterly monstrous
boards of legendary creatures in one or
two turns, and passing the turn to a
player who has Jodah on the field feels
like rolling the dice on whether or not
you take lethal combat damage this turn.
For this reason, Jodah tends to eat
removal like few others, being more or
less a kill on sight commander at most
tables, alongside other powerhouses like
Winota and Turgrid.
This might be fine if you're prepared
for it, and you could even do what my
brother did and engineer your Jodah deck
to have maximal access to protective
cards in place of a bit of
explosiveness.
But an unknowing player who throws
together a Jodah deck and expects to be
able to assemble an army of 9 12/12s in
peace might have a rude awakening when
they pull up to a table and have their
commander reacted to appropriately. This
points to the biggest critique I'd lodge
at the glass cannoniest of commanders,
the ones with the highest ratio of
explosive power to resilience. They act
like a sort of bait, attracting players
who are understandably seeking out big
exciting plays, and then putting these
players in situations where their
opponents have few choices but to bully
their decks' terrifying commander off
the field repeatedly.
All of this might feel like a hit piece
on these sorts of glass cannon
commanders, and maybe even all
commanders that lean more explosive and
are more fragile.
However, I don't want this video to be
misread as saying that these decks
shouldn't be played or have no redeeming
qualities.
There is an allure to playing a deck
that gets going fast, that does
something opponents find scary, and that
forces the table to wake up, even if it
doesn't recover well.
Part of the appeal is that it puts a
strong emphasis on the early and
midgame, almost serving as a test for
how long a player can extend this
period, and how much explosive power
they can pack into it. My most powerful
deck doesn't really have a late game
plan, and though this can mean being
less relevant in a game that goes that
far, it also means that midgame turns
are far more exciting and rich in
decision-making for me, which can be a
lot of fun.
As another example that's even more
emblematic of this philosophy, I played
several games with a Breena deck at
Magic Con Atlanta recently.
In my games against a mixture of
high-bracket three and low-bracket four
decks, I'd typically get off to a strong
and attention-grabbing start with
several creatures loaded up with plus
one plus one counters and swinging in
big at opponents. But each game I'd
inevitably get my board whittled down
and see my game plan start to stall out.
I lost every game I played with this
deck, but in every game it also felt
like I had a shot at winning, and each
game also had an interesting narrative
arc that I played a major role in. I was
the villain, the biggest baddest deck
around on turn five, and I was usually
able to smack away half the collective
health of my opponents before my
eventual decline.
I didn't win those games, but I sure
played a lot of Magic: The Gathering
during them. Really, the takeaway here
is not to not play glass cannon decks or
glass cannon commanders, but rather to
know when you're playing these sorts of
commanders, and to make an active
decision about whether that's what you
want to be doing.
I would argue that Kaalia makes for a
kind of bad precon commander for the
same reason I wouldn't hand a Jodah deck
to a newer player, because I don't think
a glass cannon commander is going to
produce consistently good play
experience for somebody just getting
into the game. It can provide a
tantalizing taste of explosive gameplay
with big cool-looking creatures, but
it's just as likely to produce
frustration when the Kaalia player eats
a bunch of interaction and stalls out
for a while.
This is not to say that a zanier or
spicier commander is never the correct
choice for a newer player, and I'm sure
there are plenty of players who had a
blast getting into EDH with a Kaalia
deck, but I personally would shoot
closer to the middle of the explosive
resilience spectrum, and let players
find their own way to the spiciest
commanders.
This is also why I'm of the opinion that
Pantlaza getting printed was the best
thing to happen to dinosaur decks in the
past five years. This is the
quintessential Timmy tribe, and for
years the primary commander for Naya
dinos was Gishath, an explosive but
fragile eight-mana enabler commander.
On the one hand, I'm sure this is a very
exciting card to have in the command
zone for a lot of players, but in
practice, I've seen it mostly serve to
make the big creature decks at Helms
feel even swingier and fall even flatter
in the face of interaction.
Seeing a Gishath player sitting there
waiting for a 10th or 12th or 14th land
drop is a pretty common occurrence, and
one I have to imagine isn't a lot of fun
for somebody newer to the Commander
format. Meanwhile, swapping Gishath out
for Pantlaza, a five-mana engine card
that often finds value or ramp off of
its triggers, makes most decks feel much
smoother and also less punishing of
suboptimal choices made in the
deck-building process.
Playing Gishath still remains a spicy
option for any dino enjoyers looking to
play with fire a bit, as it should be,
but it's good that it's no longer the
default choice for all dinosaur players.
One final thing it's worth talking about
is how to know when a commander falls
into that sort of glass cannon
classification.
There isn't an exact description, but
these are a few attributes to keep an
eye out for, in descending order of
glass cannoniness.
One, decks with the commander struggle
to hold onto gained resources through
setbacks. Most decks that are having an
explosive sequence of turns will gain
mana, draw cards, set up permanents of
various types, and use other zones to
solidify their advantage into the longer
game if they can't figure out how to win
on the spot. If you're way ahead and
either half of a Cleansing Nova causes
you to lose basically all of that
advantage, you're playing a glass cannon
deck and your commander might be a glass
cannon commander.
Two,
the commander plays an essential role in
the deck and has few to no replacements
within the deck. If your commander fills
an important task and you don't have
great ways of accomplishing that task
with any other cards, you're putting a
lot of pressure on them to stay alive,
and much of your deck's power is
concentrated onto a singular point of
failure.
Three, the difference between the deck's
floor and ceiling is dramatic. Instead
of floor and ceiling, you could think
about the deck's 80th percentile game
versus the deck's 20th percentile game.
If the above-average game sees the deck
exploding out of control and the
below-average game sees the deck
floundering, you're looking at an
inconsistent deck if nothing else.
If these describe a commander or deck
you're interested in, it doesn't mean
you shouldn't play it. You should,
however, think about whether these
attributes will create a good play
experience for you, and if you do choose
to build the deck, these are some things
to keep in the back of your mind as
things to mitigate if you find stall
outs un-fun. Commander choice, as with
most things in EDH, is a decision best
made with intentionality. Know what
you're getting into and you'll have more
fun in the games to come.
Thanks for watching, and thanks to
Archidekt for supporting the channel.
Archidekt's nice UI and flexible
category system make me happy to spend
way too much time brewing random
nonsense there. A link to my decks is in
the description. I also want to thank my
supporters on Patreon and YouTube, some
of whom are on screen now. Both my
patrons and my YouTube members get bonus
videos whenever I feel like making them,
usually about one a month. And I'm also
taking submissions for my fall supporter
deck review. If any of that sounds
interesting to you, a link to my Patreon
is in the description.